so let's now review some of these clips
of trump lawyer Alina Haba
um asked about
the documents and the empty folders
marked top secret and all of it so as a
reminder one of the things we learned
last week was that among the documents
recovered by the FBI from Trump's house
there were also empty folders marked top
secret now obviously if you see an empty
mold folder marked top secret you say
well where's the document that was in it
it's extraordinarily unlikely that
Donald Trump took empty folders so
there's probably more documents
somewhere uh Trump attorney Elena Haba
was asked about this and she started
joking about memes and invisible
documents check this out yeah obviously
and then the other thing too that we we
can't get past is that these envelopes
most of them were empty
what is that I don't know I saw this
meme that was very funny
um on Instagram I believe it was and
notice that she says I don't know what
it means and quickly switches to talking
about memes
that it's amazing at first it was the
codes to the nuclear weapons now it's
invisible classified documents
um you know it could mean anything I
don't know it could mean that they gave
those documents to Nara and to the FBI
prior as you know which they had done
now think about that this is the best
now she gives explanations that make no
sense her first claim is maybe the full
the top secret folders were empty
because Trump returned the documents
you're saying he would return the
documents and not the folder that
doesn't make any sense whatsoever so
that one's not believable
um it could mean there was nothing in
them
there was nothing in them so there was
nothing in them also doesn't make sense
because Trump's legal team and Trump
himself have insisted that the documents
there were documents that they shouldn't
be able to be reviewed as evidenced by
the Department of Justice so if there
were no documents why would Trump be
arguing that the documents shouldn't be
be reviewed by the FBI if there were no
documents he would say there were no
documents it could mean they're
invisible if you're you know in their
Administration I truly don't know you
know okay there might there might be
invisible documents so as as always the
explanations contradict maybe there were
never any documents in there then why
did Trump's legal team build a defense
based on the fact that there were
documents there that doesn't make any
sense maybe he returned the documents
but he kept the folders that doesn't
make any sense either it only creates
more questions and by the way just a
really funny extra note from this
interview she did try to Pivot to Hunter
Biden it's beyond parody at this point
but she tried meanwhile we have Hunter
Biden
[Music]
the laptop from hell and it just won't
be investigated by anybody so the Trump
legal team at odds with itself about
what is going on and what we are very
rapidly learning is this is very very
bad make sure you're following us on
Instagram at davidpackman show